Going to school in New Orleans in the
early 2000s was dismal, with only one in
four children scoring at their standard
grade level. The City School Board was so
corrupt that the FBI started an
investigation and eventually put its
president and 30 others into jail. On top
of this almost all of the teachers were
organized in unions. This ensured that
even the worst teachers kept their job
for life. Idealistic educators and
politicians tried to change the system
but their efforts were blocked by those
in charge who did everything possible to
keep things as they were. Then things got
worse. In 2005 Katrina, a massive
hurricane, struck the city and destroyed
virtually everything including all
schools. As a result, everyone left the
city. Kids stopped going to school. The
school board lost all of its funding and
the teachers lost their jobs leading to
unions losing all of their members. It
was a true disaster for everyone. In the
aftermath of Katrina politicians,
bureaucrats and educators saw an
opportunity to finally bring change
upon a system that had previously failed
so many kids in such a miserable way.
Under the leadership of governor
Kathleen Blanco it was concluded that
while they didn't know the best solution
they did know that the system had to be
created using trial and error and
experimentation. They had an idea: Instead
of running a top-down system of state
schools, their idea was to allow
independent charter schools to take over.
Charters are schools that are fully
state-funded, free of charge and run by
independent entrepreneurs who follow
their mission. Charter schools hire their
own teachers and set up their own
curriculums. They often even build their
own facilities and then compete with one
another to attract new students. As a
result of this bold effort to reform
a lot of philanthropists and nonprofit
organizations invested into New Orleans
education and hundreds of charter
schools opened up. Parents and their
children suddenly had a lot of choices
in picking schools aligned with their
ideas regarding quality education. The
schools that didn't attract enough
children closed down again.
in 2019, 15 years later, almost half of
all students performed at grade level.
High school graduation rates increased
and college outcomes became
significantly better. New Orleans had
become the first large American city
that does not operate a single
traditional public school. The story of
New Orleans schools shows what is
possible when old structures break down
and people have no choice but to leave a
damaged system. Good people who were
stuck in a bad system then get an
opportunity to start fresh. Parents and
children have the opportunity to choose
for themselves the type of schools that
they believe in. How are the schools
organized in your country? Do you think
that a reform of that system would
benefit the students? If so, what change
would you propose?
If you like this video and the way we
explain the subject subscribe to our
channel. We try to explain complex
subjects in simple language and cartoons
to support students all around the world
in their learning, if you want to support
us you can go to www.patreon.com/sprouts
and donate. just $1 from many fans makes a big difference!